[Music]
we are here today
to protect life
[Applause]
we are here today to defend those
who can't defend themselves this will
represent uh the most significant
protections for life that have been
enacted in this state in a generation
now that was governor desantis just two
weeks ago signing into law a bill that
prohibits abortions
after 15 weeks unless the mother's life
is at risk or the baby will suffer from
a fatal abnormality and that legislation
was very important to my next guess
after suffering a stroke when pregnant
with her older sister
doctors and her family recommended
congresswoman kat kamik's mom have an
abortion when she was pregnant with her
now the advice didn't sit right with her
mom and she made the courageous decision
to go through with a very difficult
pregnancy
that decision informed congresswoman
kamik's position on life and she's now
the leader of the house pro-life caucus
god is good also with us is terry
kellogg a florida mom who adopted a
little girl named hope
after she survived an attempted abortion
at just 10 and a half weeks gestation
unbelievable story welcome to both of
you um congresswoman uh something that
the abortion fight is losing um they
think it's losing one for the
republicans
your response to young voters especially
young women who've been fed so many lies
about this issue
well first and foremost you know i i
have to think about the fact that as the
youngest republican woman in congress
today
i stand here
basically an abortion survivor
and on the cusp of being amongst the
generation that is post roe v wade
millennials are the pro-life generation
and so that is incredibly important to
me and when i think about how the left
has really cornered the market
effectively shadow banning the pro-life
movement through big tech through
media they have had every opportunity to
tell the facts and to tell the truth but
they don't have the facts and they don't
have the truth
those of us in the pro-life movement do
we've got science on our side we've got
god on our side and we will be
victorious and end roe v wade in this
time
terry
your story terry is such a powerful one
when i first read about you and your
daughter
i'm i'm a mom of an adopted um
daughter and two adopted sons
your story was so
i was so moving i mean i get i get
teared up just thinking about it
briefly recap
why you made the decision you did and
why people should pay attention to this
issue now
when
we decided that we wanted to adopt and i
was going to be a special education
teacher so i was
i was open to um special needs children
and i knew that they were hard to place
and that's how i
was open to when i heard about hope
and her special needs through this
christian adoption agency and you were
called to do this i was yes it had been
placed on my heart
and she's been a blessing
it's it's been what we know and it's
been difficult but i mean being a mother
is difficult period but the blessings
have far outweighed it
and god's god is um
he's just opened doors for us to share
our story
which you know is
it takes a lot for someone to understand
exactly what happened and when we share
it
like what happened to her head
and we tell her when we tell people when
she was in 10 weeks gestation like you
had said that which would have been
about the size of this little baby
first trimester
and that's when her birth mom went and
had an abortion
and
thought it had worked and it didn't and
she left not knowing she was still
pregnant and then she felt movement
and then at five and a half months and
then she chose life she chose adoption
and didn't know anything was wrong with
her and then she delivered early and
then they knew they were going to have
to play sir with this
special needs adoption agency
there are angels on earth walking among
us and i think
you are one of them and hope is here
tonight
hope uh i'm so glad you're here uh
you're a witness and a living witness
uh to the evils um
that
we can avoid by choosing the right thing
why is this so important and why do
people need to pay attention to this
i think
because they need to choose
life for their child
and even though it may not be easy
they should not choose abortion
they should choose life for their child
because even for me
i don't know what i was going through
until god sent
a very special person in my life
and that special person is my mother
[Music]
congresswoman
here's what one planned parenthood
doctor
said
about laws such as what governor
desantis passed uh yesterday in oklahoma
passed a six-week abortion ban modeled
on what texas did this is what planned
parenthood is trying to sell
and so you're making it so that people
of low incomes
cannot
obtain abortions and so you're
disproportionately controlling people
that are black and brown like i said low
income
um and so a law that disproportionately
affects that group of people
is a white supremacist law
so for more
black and brown babies to be born is now
by that logic racist congresswoman
it's amazing how the left can seemingly
spin anything
they perpetuate a culture of victimhood
but we in this room uh people across
america know that victimhood is not a
virtue it is a condition and if they
were smart in particular that doctor who
we just heard they would recognize that
planned parenthood was founded by
someone who championed eugenics
the number one race that is terminated
in this country are black babies and the
pro-life movement is about empowerment
it's about empowering women it's about
giving a voice to those little girls
that are going to be aborted and that
goes for the the white little girls the
black little girls brown little girls we
don't see color in the pro-life movement
and so it's a real slap in the face to
every single person man and woman who
has championed and advocated the voice
of pre-born children it is really a
shame and again the left knows this is a
losing issue because the pro-life
movement we're winning well and i would
say the left would say that hope
was not human yes when they attempted to
abort hope she wasn't humid
human
heart
voice
love yes mother's day is coming up i
can't think of a better
segment that we could have done and i'm
going to start bawling so we have to get
out thank you terry thank you hope for
speaking out thank you congresswoman you
are the future of this party and we
really really appreciate you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else